the world is coming undone imperial  flags rain across the galaxy  can you be trusted without your shackles  let's just get this over with shall we  we've a mission for you  a major weapons test is imminent we need  to know how to destroy  if you're really doing this I want to  help  good  I've been recruiting through the  rebellion for a long time destroyed our  aside the Empire now  I fear nothing all is as the force will  see  the captain says you are a friend I will  not kill you  Thanks there is a much time every day  they grow stronger  there was a ninety seven point six  percent chance of failure  it means well  this is our chance to make a real  difference  are you with me  all the way